in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some nursery experts with
their GCS upload performance will we
rock this problem to sleep stay tuned to
find out
bundle cam is a company that helps
provide peace of mind through durable
high performance nursery cameras their
setup was pretty simple
every half second the camera would snap
a photo and store it locally later a
batch of those photos would be uploaded
to Google Cloud storage
for display and analysis the problem was
that they were seeing that their upload
times for a batch of images was
painfully slow during the course of 20
minutes this slowdown would result in a
serious backlog of images that needed
uploading eventually resulting in the
camera running out of memory and
stopping working at first glance this
could be a cloud storage issue so let's
run down the list of things to test
firstly we ran perf diag on a sample
bucket that they created and verified
that it had a high throughput from
clients in the region this meant that
the bucket itself was performing
properly in terms of connection and
upload speed from the client so that
wasn't our problem next we checked that
they were using the fastest API as we've
shown the GS util API tends to be a tad
slower than the direct API counterpart
but that wasn't the problem either the
cameras were on embedded hardware so
they were forced to use the direct api's
rather than GS util and they were using
the parallel upload API so again no
problem there at this point I needed to
do some research myself so I turned to
Michael use 2017 next talk where he
provided details on how GCS works behind
the scenes the important bit for us goes
something like this
when uploading files to GCS the load
balancer will use file names to decide
how to distribute connections between
shards to handle upload as such the more
diverse the file names the better the
system can balance the load likewise the
more similar the file names the harder
it is to reach peak performance when
there's contention to GCS and that was
exactly our issue the developer was
using the timestamp in the file path
running right into this performance
problem the fix for bundle cam was
pretty simple for pending the hash of
the file name to the file name itself
which allowed GCS to better partition
the fixed range into shards for better
performance you can see the difference
between the linear file names and the
hashed ones pretty easily to learn more
about how bundle cam improved their
upload performance check out the Related
article linked in the description below
and don't forget to check out the rest
of our cloud performance Atlas content
because when it comes to performance
every millisecond counts